[Musique]
on va quelquefois chez eux mais aussi
elle a qui veulent pas venir chez nous
moi je croyais pas ce qu'il va pas venir
chez nous parce que c'est ce que le pont
il leur fait il leur fait peur mais bon
il y en a qui ont peur comme ça il y en
a je connais des amis ben je leur dit
pas bien ils veulent pas c'est parce que
je passe en moi j'ai une amie lm je lui
dis de venir avec moi au port mais elle
trouve quelque chose pour ne pas lire
par exemple en est un joueur à la mairie
et quelque chose comme ça il y en a qui
disent vraiment malheur à veux pas mais
peut-être qu'il ya des gens qui veulent
pas venir au port parce que on est
peut-être tous regroupés arabe et arabe
peut-être que qu'il y en a qui qui ont
peur du pont peut-être qu'il y en a qui
ont peur des enfants peut-être que et
plusieurs raisons moi c'est j'habiterai
pas ici si je serai un français et un
cas pas moi il me dirait de venir ici si
je vois rsa c'est la première et
dernière fois que je mettrai les pieds
ici
[Musique]
voilà dans la cité on est entre 4 août
précisément on est dans un trou
dans la cité ya sans famille sans
compter les célibataires aussi
il ya que des immigrés d un peu tous des
algériens des tunisiens des marocains
des portugais meilleur club français
[Musique]
on a les dents jeune fille et je pensais
tout le temps par tunnel il n'y a pas
d'autre chemin
on est isolé par rapport à juillet quel
cinéma bibliothèque où ils ont des jeux
et puis la pharmacie les docteurs et les
boutiques
ils sont tous prêts tandis que chez nous
avions marchand qui vont trop cher on
parle pas de la cité leur assistance et
quand par exemple il faut que les francs
les arabistes offres soient gentils avec
les français les français soient
inquiets avec les arabes
je trouve que leur assise plus ça fait
de père en fils parce qu'à l'école le
péridy au christ si je te vois jouer
avec l'algérie en gare à toi ce qui aura
ce soir
alors le fils comme il écoute son père
il joue pas quel gardien il lui dit
écoute mon père veut pas que jouer avec
toi parce que tu es algérien toile
chaque pierre chaque race et racistes au
litre contre l'autre y'a pas que les
français qui sont racistes à il peut
avoir des algériens des chinois mais
tous derrière même des algériens ils ont
ils veulent pas de loire à côté d'eux
ils ont peur en effet c'est ma première
année de 6e b j'avais noir dans ma
classe bas enfin moi moi je dis
franchement de vos projets peur
mais il ne compte que mon père balayeur
puma mais rien n'est sérieux jardinier
dubaï et c'est que moi je vois pas
français à travailler dans la poubelle
ou bien dans les travaux prennent fin
les immeubles
moi je les vois surtout dans les bureaux
avec eux belle cravate bal caustique nos
parents transports on fait quand même
partie à peu de la france parce qu'on
est nés en france c'est comme si on
était un peu français no 6 si les
insultes assez comme ceux qui
s'insultent un peu la france
j'ai fait les éditeurs martinique oui
jusqu'à l'âge de 9 ans et puis
j'avais une maîtresse c'était une
blanche certaines françaises aient pensé
avoir tous les droits sur nous et
pensait qu'ils étaient supérieurs nous
puisqu'elle avait la peau blanche et
nous on avait la peau noire
on disait oh oui je serai au pays
j'ai le droit de faire tout ce que je
fais de vous avant j'avais un complexe
quand j'entrais dans fin au début de
l'année quand j'entrais dans l'école ont
le plus besoin ne se trouvait la semaine
noire alors à deux et je toujours grave
que ça marche pas quoique qui est une
différence entre nous les élèves noirs
et les élèves européens et en fin de
compte ça très bien marché dans certains
cours dès qu'il ya une bêtise de fait on
croit que c'est nous alors tout de suite
ni un monstre est quoi si c'est pas
possible on s'énerve quoi
or à chaque fois quelque chose de faire
bon nous regarde tout le temps sans
visite quand quelqu'un de couleur dans
un magasin et bien tout de suite ceux
qui ceux qui font partie du magasin ils
viennent tout de suite affolé de pâques
ont compris quelque chose qu'on voit les
jeunes disent que ce que vous voulez
mademoiselle qu'est ce qu'il ya vous
pouvez commencer à quelque chose
ils ont peur qu'on comprenne quelque
chose parce qu'on est de couleur alors
ils pensent qu'on les voleurs césar est
souvent dans tout le magasin et moi je
m'en avait une fois je suis entré pour
essayer un patin l'ombre bien sûr il
était très joli mais ça ne voulait pas
dire pour ça que j'aime pas rageant pour
payer lui
alors j'ai regardé tout je les aime dit
oui
vous voulez vous voulez pas j'ai dit bon
ben je regarde un peu est-ce que vous
avez de l'argent pour payer moi alors je
me suis senti vexé pas alors j'ai dit ah
ben oui j'ai de l'argent mais puisque
c'est comme ça j'en ai plus envie que je
sorte bain d'eau à je réfléchissais je
comprenais parents ça va aller toucher 1
j'ai failli pourrait se jouer à fond
[Musique]
revue camarades je n'ai plus de problème
j'en ai eu à vendre a ajouté plus jeunes
enfin j'ai pas vieille parce que les
femmes et camarades dit réfléchissez pas
mêmes
il répétait ce qu'ils avaient entendu
dire chez eux dans leur famille il ya
des parents qui ne s'est peut-être pas
que tes doigts reviennent chez eux
il y avait une copine et puis c'était
son anniversaire et puis évidemment
invité à son anniversaire mais moi je
voulais bien mis sa mère à la refuser
pascal a dit kallas et de palois est là
c'est peut-être pas de noirs bien réel
soulier la porte de chez elle
je pense qu'un certain âge les enfants
nos camarades prennent la liberté de
réfléchir mais moi c'est par exemple
quand il était plus jeune il était
raciste avec des comportements un peu
parce que la sq a évolué les enfants
sont pas pareil c'est pas comme le temps
d'avant changer quoi ils ont appris que
enfin quand on n'a rien de différent
avec eux qu'on est pareils et ils sont
plus aussi façon plus fraternelle sont
plus amicaux on a la même peau mais
c'est pas la même couleur or on respire
la mémère les familles la couche comme
comme tout le monde
comment dire on est tous pareils il n'y
a pas un point de différence il ya bien
des blanches qu'ils essayent de se faire
bronzer bon bah je sais pas si ça c'est
pas l'un tout sépare et bien je suis une
fille qui me dit pourquoi tu es noir
alors je lui dis ben pourquoi il ya des
fleurs de toutes les couleurs sur la
terre alors un petit bon ben je sais pas
mais je suis dit mais moi je suis là
parce que je suis noir c'est tout puis
un jour sur deux cités dans le métro et
puis tu veux rien dame qui était une
cité nazairienne et puis elle est
enceinte puis la vie lire très très
fatiguée alors je laisse ma place est
derrière moi j'attends deux personnages
gars qui disait à regarder cette
négresse là est la bonne étape à sa une
agir y est j'ai pas mais ils ont trouvé
ça bizarre que je laisse ma place avant
moi ça m'a choqué comme a dit ça commnce
h après je rentrais chez moi mais je me
suis pas un crayon puis me suis dit
pourquoi les gens sont comme ça qu'est
ce qu'on aura fait on est tous pareil
sauf mal à cola cola de la religion qui
changent je sais pas moi ça m'énerve un
camp puis surtout depuis ce jour là quoi
filer jouer le monde je me pose des
questions pour que les gens sont comme
ça paie moi j'espère mais si jamais ça
si jamais ça disparaît ben pour moi ce
sera un miracle je suis au vietnam
j'étais partagé enfin entre deux races
différentes vues j'étais métis j'avais
enfin j'avais beaucoup de mal à faire
venir les autres la moins ça pour qu'ils
viennent me voir parce que j'avais un
père français donc j'étais moins typé
que et ça il faisait une grande
différence
mais par rapport aux français c'était
totalement différent je me mettais dans
un panier des autres parce que j'avais
les yeux [ __ ] et ça j'étais une
vietnamienne l'échauffement j'avais
vraiment pas de race pour ainsi dire
j'étais partagé entre les deux je ne
sais pas comment qui je suis en effet je
leur disais jeté un vase yens bon bah
c'est pas normal tel est le type est
donc très vite la mienne c'était très
dur de leur faire accepter que j'étais à
la fois vietnamienne et française heures
il comprenait pas ça
[Musique]
j'étais entouré que des personnes de la
même race que - et des caves et des
français qui venaient dans notre dans
notre école
on était enfin on était très méchante
ont été agressifs parce que on savait
qu'ils étaient plus forts que nous ils
avaient un niveau d'étude fin la culture
savait plus de choses que nous mais
comme nous on apprenait leur langue
on était plus ou moins enfin on était
jaloux on voulait réussir autant que
donc on les maîtrise et soi disant on
les mettait à part et enfin en faisait
une petite bande des petites méchancetés
de gamme haf puis vraiment on leur mener
la vie dure à l'école
je rêve habitant en france je suis
partie à cause de la guerre
je suis arrivé juste avant et je suis
parti avec mes parents mon père est
français ma mère avec la mienne est pour
moi partir en france c'était vraiment un
rêve pour partir en vacances je voyais
la france à travers tout ce que mon père
me racontait et c'était formidable
j'étais pressé d'aller en france voir la
france et je ne savais pas que j'avais
quitté mon pays pour toujours pour ainsi
dire et quand je suis venu en france et
dans les premiers temps je suis beaucoup
de problèmes à m'adapter
quoique je savais par les français mais
c'était enfin c'était très très dur vous
excitez pas le même mode de vie les
mêmes coutumes je me retrouvais dépaysé
je ne savais même plus avec qui parler
parce que bon bah on me regardait de la
tête jusqu'aux pieds parce que je suis
pas français ça se voit
j'ai essayé on était très très aisée
n'étaient les petits bourgeois et quand
on est en france à changer parce que ce
n'était pas la même le mode de vie
c'était pas pareil
puis la visite est plus cher on ne
pouvait pas voir ce qu'on voulait et mon
père et il est descendu fin tout au bas
de l'échelle
il a dû tout recommencer et c'était très
très dur pour lui de s'adapter même dans
son propre pays
vu qu'il a quitté la france très très
jeune il s'est installé au vietnam
pendant 13 ans et là bas ils étaient
habitués enfin il est habitué à
commander si vous voulez et maintenant
quand il vient quand il est revenu en
france il était sous les ordres de
quelqu'un d'autre et ça c'était très
très dur aussi pour lui d'accepter ça
même étant la france est même que j'ai
un père français je me sens vite la
mienne parce qu'on a toujours répété et
je suis pas que vraiment je me sens et
n'amène même maintenant quoi je suis dit
ma mère d'origine
si on a l'habitude j'aime dans une
caravane passe quand on peut voyager et
puis on a plusieurs pays tandis que dans
une maison
restez plagne a gelé quoi dans la même
place
[Musique]
omnivision karawan parce qu'on voit plus
de choses par maison il sait qu'une
pièce du milieu de la caravane comme hlm
on hlm ou des paroles avant tient les
barreaux d'abord parce que sa grande
part posé par radama d'avoir les
caennais
[Musique]
il y en a qui nous aiment pas des fois
des gens patients et franck ils disent
qu'on est salie disque on sale [ __ ] us
pas parce qu il divo conclave temps des
heures débat qui disent que c'est des
poubelles alors qu'en 10e moment il ya
des gens il va falloir dit on peut jouer
avec vous lors jette des gitans sur
l'épreuve mourad ont joué seulement + 3
fort un ensemble puis en close up dans
leur coin tellement chaud dans le froid
[Musique]